China is performing a minor
miracle right now.
They are taking
captive-born pandas
and releasing them back
into the wild.
They're also creating corridors
and creating more habitat
for pandas
and a whole host of
other species.
So, I had front row
access to this,
and this was quite a
big privilege,
because no foreigners have ever
been allowed to cover this.
I was there with a film team
and we were covering this
incredible moment as Hope,
that was her name,
was taking her first
trepid steps
out into the wild for
the first time.
- Me trying to be empathetic.
- ( audience laughter )
I dressed up in a ghillie suit
because I didn't want
to scare her
when she was taking those
steps out into the wild.
And the director of the panda
program, Director Zhang Hemin,
also called Papa Panda,
saw me and he came
running up to me
and he gave me a
hug and he said,
"You will get to hold
two baby pandas."
( audience laughter )
"President Obama,
he only held one."
( audience laughter )
I know! It's so crazy!
( laughs )
So they laid out their
bumper crop
that year of baby pandas.
And then I got to go back,
and this is very recent,
this is this year.
They actually had even a bigger
bumper crop,
I think it was twenty
six baby pandas born.
It's incredible.
( laughs )
( audience laughter )
They will melt
your heart, truly.
So they did something amazing.
They cracked the code how
you breed them.
Because for a long time,
for fifteen years,
they couldn't figure out how,
you know,
how you successfully
breed the pandas.
But it turns out,
pandas are like humans.
They're picky.
They don't have eHarmony
or Match.com.
So, it took sort of realizing
they needed to find a partner
that they liked.
And the females only are
able to have a baby--
they basically have
24 to 72 hours to get pregnant.
That's it, an entire year.
So it's a very narrow window
and you have to find the
right partner for her.
So they've done that.
And what is so incredible is
they're born blind, deaf and
just a little squiggle
of a thing.
And completely helpless.
But the mothers are incredible,
they just take such
good care.
They won't-- for days, they go
without water and food and
they just hold on to their
babies and take care of them.
- They're one of the fastest--
- ( audience laughter )
fastest growing mammals.
So, this little guy is
maybe a month old.
So they grow fast.
And literally every week I'd go
into the incubator room and
they would just grow in
front of your eyes. Incredible.